et on rampe, sur les mains et les genoux,
pour entrer dans la navette, un à la fois,
et vous vous hissez jusqu'à votre fauteuil.
Et vous vous affalez dedans sur le dos.
La porte se ferme,
et tout à coup,
ce qui était une vie de rêves et de dénis,
est en train de devenir réel.
Une chose dont j'ai rêvée,
que j'ai choisie de faire quand j'avais 9 ans,
va soudainement, dans les minutes à venir,
se réaliser pour de vrai.
Dans le monde des astronautes,
la navette est un véhicule très complexe.
C'est la machine volante la plus complexe qui n'a jamais été construite.
Les astronautes ont un dicton qui est le suivant :
Il n'y a aucun problème grave
que tu ne puisses rendre pire.
(Rires)
Vous faites très attention dans le cockpit.
Vous pensez à ce tout que vous devrez peut-être faire,
tous les boutons et les interrupteurs à enclencher.
Alors que l'instant se rapproche de plus en plus,
l'excitation s'accumule.
À environ 3 minutes et demi du décollage,
les immenses moteurs à l'arrière,
gros comme d'énormes cloches d'église,
se balancent d'avant en d'arrière
et ils sont si massifs qu'ils balancent le véhicule en entier,
comme si le véhicule était vivant en-dessous de vous,
comme un éléphant agenouillé qui se relève.
Puis environ 30 secondes avant le départ,
le véhicule est complètement vivant –
il est prêt à partir –
les unités de calcul sont fonctionnelles,
les ordinateurs sont autonomes,
il est l'heure de quitter la planète.
15 secondes avant le départ, on entend ça :
(Vidéo) Voix : 12, 11, 10,
9, 8, 7, 6 —
(La navette spatiale se prépare à décoller)
– mise à feu, 2, 1,
allumage des propulseurs d'appoint et décollage de la navette spatiale Discovery,
qui retourne à la station spatiale, ouvrant la voie à...
(La navette spatiale décolle)
Chris Hadfield : C'est incroyablement puissant
d'être à bord d'un de ces engins.
Il y a quelque chose qui vous saisit
qui est largement plus puissant que soi.
Ça vous secoue si fort que vous ne pouvez pas vous concentrer
sur les instruments devant vous.
C'est comme si vous étiez dans la gueule d'un chien colossal,
comme si un pied appuyait le creux de votre dos
pour vous pousser dans l'espace,
qui vous donne une accélération ascendante,
vous accompagne au long de votre ascension,
et vous êtes dans une situation très complexe –
à faire attention, à observer la navette
qui passe par toutes les étapes
avec un sourire grandissant sur le visage.
Après deux minutes, les propulseurs d'appoint se détachent
et il ne reste que les moteurs liquides,
à l'hydrogène et à l'oxygène.
C'est comme conduire un dragster
avec la pédale au plancher,
et vous accélérez comme si vous n'aviez jamais accéléré.
Vous devenez de plus en plus léger,
la poussée devient de plus en plus écrasante.
C'est comme si quelqu'un vous versait du ciment.
Jusqu'à ce qu'enfin,
après environ 8 minutes et 40 secondes,
on atteint exactement la bonne altitude,
exactement la bonne vitesse,
on est dans la bonne direction, le moteur s'éteint
et nous sommes en impesanteur.
Et nous sommes vivants.
C'est une expérience incroyable.
Mais pourquoi prenons-nous ce risque ?
Pourquoi faire quelque chose de si dangereux ?
Dans mon cas, la réponse est assez simple.
J'avais l'inspiration lorsque j'étais jeune
que c'était ce que je voulais faire.
J'avais vu les premiers hommes marcher sur la Lune
et pour moi, c'était juste évident.
Je voulais faire ça d'une façon ou d'une autre.
Mais la véritable question est plutôt :
comment confronter le danger,
ainsi que la peur qui l'accompagne ?
Comment surpasser sa peur devant le danger ?
Et avec ce but en tête, en pensant où ça pourrait me mener,
j'ai dédié ma vie
à chercher tous les petits détails qui permettraient
de rendre cela possible,
de pouvoir décoller et aider à bâtir une station spatiale
où vous êtes à bord d'un objet de 500 tonnes,
qui tourne autour de la planète à 5 miles par seconde,
8 kilomètres par seconde,
qui en fait le tour 16 fois par jour,
avec des expériences à bord qui nous apprennent
de quoi est fait l'univers
et il y en a 200 d'entre elles dont il faut s'occuper.
Mais peut-être plus important encore,
cela nous permet de voir le monde sous un angle
qu'il serait impossible de percevoir autrement.
Être capable d'observer le monde d'en haut.
Et si votre mâchoire pouvait tomber, elle tomberait –
la splendeur à couper le souffle de l'astre tournant
comme une galerie d'art autopropulsée
d'une beauté fantastique et constamment changeante qu'est notre monde.
Et vous voyez, à cause de la vitesse,
un lever ou un coucher de soleil toutes les 45 minutes
pendant une demie année.
La partie la plus magnifique de tout cela,
c'est de sortir marcher dans l'espace.
Vous êtes dans une navette spatiale monoplace
qu'est votre scaphandre spatial,
et vous parcourez l'espace avec la planète.
C'est une perspective complètement différente ;
vous ne regardez pas l'univers d'en-bas,
vous parcourez l'univers avec la Terre.
Vous vous tenez d'une main
en regardant la Terre tourner en-dessous de vous.
Elle rugit silencieusement
avec ses couleurs et textures qu'elle épanche
de façon hypnotisante à côté de vous.
Si vous arrivez à détacher vos yeux de cette vue,
vous regardez sous votre bras
pour contempler tout le reste.
L'obscurité insondable
d'une texture qui laisse penser que vous pourriez y plonger la main.
Vous vous tenez d'une main.
Le seul lien qui vous relie aux 7 autres milliards d'humains.
J'étais à l'extérieur lors de ma première sortie dans l'espace
quand mon œil gauche est devenu aveugle,
et je ne savais pas pourquoi.
Soudainement, il s'est refermé
très douloureusement
et je ne pouvais pas en déterminer la cause.
Je me demandais : et maintenant ?
Je me suis dit : c'est peut-être pour ça que nous avons 2 yeux,
et j'ai continué à travailler.
Malheureusement, sans gravité,
les larmes ne coulent pas.
Elles s'agglutinent en une boule qui ne cesse de s'élargir
qui se mélange avec on ne sait quoi d'autre,
jusqu'à ce que la boule devienne tellement grosse
que la tension superficielle l'amène sur le nez
comme une petite chute d'eau
et "goosh", ça passe dans votre autre œil.
À ce moment-là, j'étais complètement aveugle,
à l'extérieur du vaisseau spatial.
Quelle est la chose la plus effrayante que vous ayez déjà faite ?
(Rires)
Les araignées, peut-être ?
Beaucoup de gens ont peur des araignées.
Vous devriez avoir peur des araignées –
elles sont terrifiantes et ont de longues jambes velues.
Les araignées comme celle-ci, la recluse brune –
c'est horrible.
Si une recluse brune vous mord,
vous développez une de ces horribles nécroses énormes à la jambe
et il se pourrait qu'il y en ait une là tout de suite
sur le fauteuil derrière vous.
Comment savoir ?
L'araignée vous tombe dessus,
et vous contractez une grande panique
parce que les araignées font peur.
Mais vous vous demander s'il y a vraiment une recluse brune
sur le fauteuil d'à côté.
Je ne sais pas. Il y en a ici ?
Si vous faites un peu de recherches, vous trouvez que dans le monde
il y a environ 50 000 espèces différentes d'araignées
et qu'à peu près deux douzaines sont venimeuses
parmi ces 50 000.
Si vous êtes au Canada, à cause des hivers froids,
ici en Colombie-Britannique, il y a environ 720,730 espèces d'araignées
et il y en a une – une seule –
qui est venimeuse,
et son venin n'est même pas mortel,
c'est plutôt comme une méchante piqûre.
Et cette araignée
possède de magnifiques taches sur son dos, comme pour indiquer :
je suis dangereuse, j'ai un gros symbole radioactif sur mon dos,
c'est la veuve noire.
Même si vous ne faites pas très attention,
vous pouvez éviter de croiser une de ces araignées –
elles vivent proche du sol,
lorsque vous vous promenez, vous ne tomberez jamais
sur une veuve noire qui va vous mordre.
Elles ne tissent pas ce type de toile,
elles les tissent plutôt dans des coins.
On l'appelle « veuve noire »
car la femelle dévore le mâle.
Elle n'a que faire de vous.
Alors en fait,
la prochaine fois que vous rentrez dans une toile d'araignée
vous n'avez pas besoin de paniquer et d'avoir une réaction primitive.
Le danger est complètement différent de la peur.
Mais comment surmontez-vous la peur ?
Comment changer votre réaction ?
La prochaine fois que vous voyez une toile,
regardez-la, assurez-vous que ce n'est pas une veuve noire, et rentrez dedans.
Quand vous en voyez une autre,
rentrez aussi dedans.
C'est juste légèrement duveteux. Pas grand chose.
L'araignée qui pourrait sortir n'est pas plus menaçante qu'une coccinelle
ou qu'un papillon.
Je vous assure qu'après être rentré dans une centaine de toiles d'araignées,
ça aura changé
votre réaction fondamentalement humaine,
votre réaction primitive,
et vous pourrez vous promener dans un parc le matin
sans être inquiété par les toiles d'araignées –
pareil pour le grenier de votre grand-mère,
ou votre sous-sol.
Vous pouvez appliquer cela à n'importe quoi.
Si vous êtes aveuglé dans l'espace,
votre réaction naturelle serait de paniquer, je pense.
Ça vous rendrait nerveux et inquiet.
Mais nous avions considéré tous les venins,
et nous nous étions entraînés avec beaucoup de toiles d'araignées.
On savait tout ce qu'il y a à savoir
sur la combinaison spatiale,
et on s'était entraîné sous l'eau des milliers de fois.
On ne s'entraîne pas que pour quand tout va bien,
on s'entraîne sur tout ce qui peut mal se passer.
Vous rencontrez constamment ces toiles d'araignée.
Non seulement sous l'eau, aussi dans des labos de réalité virtuelle
avec un casque et des gants
pour que ça vous paraisse réel.
Donc quand vous sortez enfin dans l'espace,
le sentiment est très différent
que si c'était pour la première fois.
Même si vous êtes aveuglé,
votre réaction naturelle de panique ne se produit pas.
Vous regardez autour et vous vous dites :
« Bon je ne vois pas,
mais je peux entendre, je peux parler,
Scott Parazynski est là avec moi.
Il peut venir m'aider. »
Nous nous étions entrainés au sauvetage d'un membre d'équipage en détresse.
Il pouvait me faire flotter comme un dirigeable
et me fourrer dans le sas si besoin.
Je pourrais retrouver mon chemin du retour.
Ce n'est pas un gros problème.
Si vous continuez à pleurer un moment,
la saleté dans vos yeux commence à se diluer
et vous recouvrez la vue.
Si vous négociez avec Houston,
ils vous laisseront continuer à travailler.
Nous avons tout fini lors de cette sortie
et, de retour à l'intérieur,
Jeff a pris des ouates de coton et a enlevé la croûte autour de mes yeux,
et il s'est avéré que c'était juste l'anti-brouillard,
une mixture d'huile et de savon qui était rentrée dans mes yeux.
Maintenant, nous utilisons la marque « formule sans larmes »,
que nous aurions sûrement dû utiliser dès le début.
(Rires)
Mais la solution,
c'est de déterminer la différence
entre le danger perçu et le danger réel,
et d'identifier le risque réel.
De quoi devriez-vous vraiment avoir peur ?
Pas juste une peur commune de mauvais présages.
Vous pouvez tout à fait changer votre réaction aux choses
pour que cela vous permette d'aller dans des endroits,
de voir et de faire des choses,
auxquelles vous n'auriez pas accès autrement.
D'où vous pourriez voir l'alios du sud du Sahara,
ou la ville de New York,
d'une façon presque onirique,
ou les motifs à carreaux des plaines d'Europe de l'Est,
ou les Grands Lacs
comme un amas de petites flaques d'eau.
D'où vous pourriez voir les failles de San Francisco
et la manière dont l'eau coule sous le pont,
sous un jour complètement différent
que ce qui vous aurait été permis
si vous n'aviez pas trouvé un moyen de conquérir vos peurs.
Vous voyez une beauté
qui ne vous aurez jamais été révélée autrement.
Il est temps de rentrer à la fin.
Ça, c'est notre navette,
le Soyouz, en petit.
Trois d'entre nous montent à bord,
ce vaisseau se détache de la station
et tombe dans l'atmosphère.
Les deux parties, ici, fondent,
elles se détachent et se désintègrent
dans l'atmosphère.
Le seul élément qui survit est cette petite capsule
que nous empruntons.
Elle tombe dans l'atmosphère.
Essentiellement,
vous êtes en train de chevaucher une météorite,
et chevaucher des météorites, ça fait peur,
c'est normal.
Mais au lieu de traverser l'atmosphère en criant,
comme vous le feriez
si vous vous retrouviez soudainement à bord d'une météorite
pour revenir sur Terre – (Rires) –
nous avions, 20 ans plus tôt,
commencé à apprendre le Russe,
et après avoir appris le Russe,
nous avons appris la mécanique orbitale en Russe,
puis la théorie du pilotage du véhicule,
et nous utilisions un simulateur
où nous pratiquions encore et encore.
Vous pouvez piloter cette météorite,
la diriger et la faire atterrir dans un cercle de 15 km
n'importe où sur Terre.
Donc en fait, quand notre équipage était de retour
dans l'atmosphère à l'intérieur du Soyouz,
on n'était pas en train de crier, on riait.
C'était amusant.
Quand le grand parachute s'est ouvert,
on savait que s'il ne s'ouvrait pas, il y en avait un 2ème
qui fonctionne grâce à un ingénieux mécanisme.
Nous sommes redescendus sur Terre dans un grand retentissement.
Voilà ce à quoi ça ressemblait,
d'atterrir dans un Soyouz, dans le Kazakhstan.
(Vidéo) Journaliste : Vous pouvez voir
l'un des hélicoptères de recherche et de sauvetage.
Une fois de plus, cet hélicoptère fait partie
d'une douzaine d'hélicoptères russes Mi-8.
Atterrissage – 3h14 et 48 secondes,
heure de Houston.
CH : Vous roulez jusqu'à un stop
comme si on avait jeté votre vaisseau
et qu'il butait dans tous les sens.
Mais vous êtes prêt.
Vous êtes dans un siège spécial,
vous savez comment fonctionnent les amortisseurs.
Les Russes vous retrouvent enfin,
ils vous traînent dehors,
vous installent sur une chaise
et vous pouvez maintenant contempler
ce qui a été l'expérience incroyable que vous avez vécue.
Vous avez pris les rêves
de ce garçon de neuf ans
qui étaient impossibles
et redoutablement effrayants,
redoutablement terrifiants,
vous les avez mis en pratique,
et vous avez trouvé un moyen de vous reprogrammer,
de changer vos peurs primitives,
ce qui vous a permis de revenir
avec une palette d'expériences et un niveau d'inspiration
à partager
qui n'aurait jamais été possible autrement.
Pour finir, ils m'ont demandé de jouer de la guitare.
Je connais cette chanson,
c'est vraiment un hommage
au génie de David Bowie.
Mais c'est aussi, je pense,
une réflexion sur le fait que nous ne sommes pas des machines
qui explorent l'univers.
Nous sommes des personnes,
et nous amenons dans d'autres endroits
cette aptitude à nous adapter,
cette aptitude à comprendre,
et cette aptitude à transformer
notre perception de nous-mêmes.
(Musique)